cut abruptly by the washington football
team
late last week quickly finds a new home
with the detroit lions a one-year deal
with a
veteran minimum salary worth i'm told up
to 2.3 million
based upon yards and touchdowns and on
the surface the lions have a crowded
house in the backfield they've got
carrion johnson second rounder in 2018
deandre
swift second rounder in 2020 why would
they need adrian peterson well the
reality is
johnson has missed 14 games in two
seasons due to injury 14 games
nearly half of his time with the team he
hasn't been able to play
and look that's not a knock on carry on
johnson it's a tough demanding position
and adrian peterson has proven since
2007 far more often than not
he can line up and go deandre swift had
an injury that knocked him out for a lot
of camp and it called into question
his availability for the month of
september so peterson gives them a guy
who can fill in for swift while swift is
getting healthy
and also a hedge against the possibility
that johnson
will get injured again and the end
result is
you know wherever adrian peterson goes
except new orleans because it didn't
work out there because they didn't want
to use him the way he wanted to be used
he's gotten opportunities and it feels
like he's going to get opportunities
with the lions and wouldn't be something
if he passes barry sanders
on the all-time rushing list while
playing for the detroit lions oh and by
the way he'll get to
play in minnesota again this year he'll
play the vikings twice i'm sure that
he was attracted to that possibility i'm
told two other teams
were interested in adrian peterson but
they wanted to wait
until after week one one of those teams
by the way
plays early in week one and possibly
wears helmets that are
painted red other than that i'm not
going to say anything more about it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports